c'est à toronto en décembre dernier que
se tenait le congrès international de
drôme
on y présentait les plus récentes
avancées technologiques de l'industrie
un secteur qui est en évolution autant
au plan commercial qu'au plan récréatif
et c'est dans le secteur récréatif que
le gouvernement canadien annonce une
série de mesures pour encadrer les
drones il sera donc maintenant interdit
de faire voler son drone la nuit à moins
de 75 mètres d'une personne ou encore
d'une habitation et on ne pourra pas le
faire voler plus haut que 90 m et à 9
kilomètres de l'aéroport ou encore d'un
héliport
les réactions des opérateurs
professionnels de drones déjà assujettis
un ensemble de restrictions sont
extrêmement positives on entrevoit ici
la fin d'un certain far west dans le
ciel canadien
on a travaillé avec ottawa nsfr
marmottes et directeur général du centre
d'excellence sur les drones à alma au
nord du québec
il ya eu peut-être à laisser aller
depuis quelques années après avoir
écouté puis de plus en plus avec les
infections c'est malheureux parce que
ces programmes un mal nécessaire pour
les quelques personnes qui sont qui
titille manque de civilité avec leurs
drones c'est ce sont ces drôles que je
fais c'est trop loin les plus dangereux
que les autres font partie de papier
qu'un des agents immobiliers déjà qu'ils
vont tourner un mariage des choses comme
ça de la sodomie les opérations qui sont
spécialisés les six heures avant un saut
ce cas d'opération et rien spécialisés
c'est seat a trouvé près à pour couper
et les gens ont suivi ceux qui vont y
opérer ont suivi une formation ils
savent qu'ils connaissent avec la main
et ils ont adhéré au reggae au guide qui
l'ont qu'ils acceptent ans puisque de
récréation c'est allé chez bear b aller
acheter son bronze est allée se promener
ce petit oiseau dont témoigne danger
mais plus que ya beaucoup de dangers
surtout quand un avion arrive à 80km un
magnifique kg a fait beaucoup beaucoup
de dommages la situation canadienne
n'est pas unique
si au canada on n'a pas loin de faire
voler au donnerez créatifs à plus de 90
m
en france par exemple l'altitude peut
atteindre 150 mètres selon un nouveau
code annoncé également récemment là bas
la question n'est pas nous en fait aucun
pays
tout récemment les autorités de la ville
de hanzhou dans le sud de la chine ont
annoncé avoir procédé à l'arrestation
d'un drone is de 23 ans qui avait eu
l'idée d'envoyer son drone filmées de
très près et à 450 mètres d'altitude
les avions à la proche de l'aéroport et
ce sur fond de soleil couchant
c'est très accessible comme vous savez
le savoy daniela qu'un faire valoir et
même moins ça fait de très belles images
de belles qualités car même avec les
petites caméras dans votre résolution
qui fournissent avec les systèmes
normalement mais les gens puissent est
une problématique justement dans les
aéroports ça fait de super belle image
avec un avion en approche mais on
comprend que c'était un des sites
d'après les plus dangereux lorsque des
avions
bernard gervais est président et
directeur général de l'association
canadienne des propriétaires et pilotes
d'aéronefs
donc c'est ça faire justement règlement
parlait justement des forces policières
âge des sites web ou si des transports
canada ce qu'on peut dénoncer les gens
qu'ils font illégalement qui l'a 75 m à
partir des bâtiments je pense que
qu'est-ce qui cherchent à rejoindre l'a6
que les gens vont en utiliser dans les
secteurs résidentiels ou près des écoles
donc ça va forcer les gens à se trouver
des avenues plus propice à des endroits
peu plus propre et justement position de
drones les sortir des quartiers anciens
parce que non seulement est un aspect
sécuritaire mais un aspect aussi les
privés que je pense que c'est de
résoudre par son outil mais encore là
aussi c'est d'être capable justement de
coincer ces gens là qui vont faire de
façon illégale
de plus en plus je pense que les jantes
sont la grc la sûreté du québec vont
être sensibilisés
parce que maintenant soit il ya
peut-être une réglementation en place
mais si les gens les agents de sûreté du
québec par exemple sont pas familiers
avec les réglementations
c'est dur d'intervenir donc je pense
qu'on a emmené la seconde seulement puis
mêmes assauts la façon que j'ai des
neveux peut-être plutôt rumeurs me dire
j'ai déjà ou commerciales qui sont
rendre qui sont prêts à offrir un
service sans permis de vols vont prendre
de risques
surprend par transports canada et par la
suite vont négocier justement les amants
pour à la veille donc il ya au canadien
qui recevront dorénavant un drone par
exemple en cadeau il faudra leur dire de
ne pas oublier de lire le manuel
d'instruction les contrevenants
s'exposent à une amende pouvant
atteindre maintenant 3000 dollars
canadiens un reportage de radio canada
international